lo que quiero hacer es hablar sobre la
diferencia entre vectores y escalares
vectores
y escalares y podrían parecer ideas muy
complicadas pero veremos que en realidad
son conceptos muy simples primero
veremos las definiciones y después les
daré varios ejemplos para que todo quede
muy claro un vector es algo que tiene
una magnitud
o tamaño y además tiene dirección en
cambio un escalar solo tiene magnitud o
tamaño y si esto no nos parece que tiene
sentido en un momento veremos un ejemplo
que les ayudará a comprenderlo
bueno digamos que aquí está el suelo y
encima del suelo tengo un ladrillo
tomo este ladrillo y lo nuevo hacia acá
a la derecha
y bueno tomo una regla y veo que movía
el ladrillo de aquí acá cinco metros mi
pregunta para usted es si mi medida de
cinco metros es un vector un escalar si
solo las dijera cinco metros ustedes
solo conocerían el tamaño del movimiento
la magnitud solamente entonces estos
cinco metros así tal cual es una escala
sería solamente una cantidad de escalar
cuando les doy el tamaño o la magnitud
de algo pero no les doy la dirección
entonces hablamos de escalares en este
caso de la distancia así que sabemos que
ese ladrillo que levante el móvil se ha
alejado a una distancia de 5 metros si
ustedes no pudieran ver este diagrama y
sólo supiera en que se movió 5 metros
pues no sabrían si se movió a la
izquierda a la derecha arriba o abajo
si queremos especificar la dirección
podríamos decir que este ladrillo se
movió 5 metros
a la derecha
aquí hemos indicado la magnitud 5 metros
y también hemos especificado la
dirección a la derecha lo que acabo de
indicar aquí es una cantidad vectorial
todo esto es un vector y cuando hablamos
de una cantidad de magnitud o tamaño e
indicamos la dirección
la versión vectorial de la distancia le
vamos a llamar desplazamiento la forma
correcta de expresar esto es decir que
el ladrillo se ha desplazado 5 metros a
la derecha o se ha movido una distancia
de 5 metros
la cantidad es escalar si no les digo la
dirección del movimiento va a ser
escalar el desplazamiento es una
cantidad vectorial cuando les digo que
se movió hacia la derecha exploremos
esto cuando hablamos de rapidez o
velocidad digamos que se recorrieron
estos 5 metros y que el cambio en el
tiempo el cambio en el tiempo cuando
moví este ladrillo 5 metros fue de 2
segundos
justo antes de mover el ladrillo mi
cronómetro marcaba 0 segundos y cuando
lo termine de mover el ladrillo marcó 2
segundos por lo que el cambio en el
tiempo o la duración es de 2 segundos y
bueno por lo que sabemos el tiempo sólo
viaja en una dirección y quizá podría
decir que el tiempo es escalar solo hay
una dirección en el tiempo al menos
mientras trabajamos con problemas
básicos de física puedes la medida de
qué tan rápido se movió ladrillo cuál es
la rapidez bueno comentamos que se movió
5 metros en dos segundos y esto es igual
a la parte escalar 5 entre 2 y las
unidades metros entre segundos si hago
esta operación se encuentre 12 es igual
a 2.5 así que la rapidez es igual a 2.5
metros por segundo mi pregunta para
ustedes si esta es una cantidad de
escalar o vectorial nos dice qué tan
rápido se movió pero no nos dice hacia
dónde se movió o en qué dirección así
que es una cantidad escala
ahora cuando decimos 5 metros a la
derecha por 2 segundos va a ser igual a
2.5 metros sobre segundo a la derecha
esto es un vector o un escalar aquí les
estoy dando la dirección del movimiento
además de la magnitud de la rapidez 2.5
metros por segundo la rapidez y aquí
está la dirección a la derecha por lo
que esto es un vector así que aquí
estamos hablando de la velocidad cuando
hablamos de posición hablamos del
desplazamiento si no mencionamos la
dirección tenemos la versión escalar y
estaremos hablando de la distancia
si hablamos de qué tan rápido se mueve
algo y damos la dirección hacia dónde se
dirige tenemos la velocidad si no damos
la dirección entonces hablaremos de
rapidez y espero que esto les haya
ayudado a comprender estos conceptos y
en los siguientes vídeos
veremos ejemplos para responder
preguntas básicas sobre qué tan rápido
va algo que está lejos viajar
o cuánto tiempo le llevará a llegar a
cierto lugar